hearing will come to order we have a
considerable amount of territory to try
to cover in a short span of time and so
I want to try to keep moving along as
rapidly as we can mr. Rodriguez I thank
you for the detail of your answers and I
want that detail I think it's very
important if we can try and keep moving
expeditiously I think it would help
everybody know I will remind people that
mr. Rodriguez will not testify as to all
things that he knows today regarding
some of these matters because we're
holding some of it for the subsequent
hearings that will follow in order to
try to keep corroborated evidence
together I'd like to go back to one area
and that is the payments to general
Noriega you talked about the 10 million
or so at one period of time and that it
varied and so forth but could you be
more specific as to how that money got
from you to general Noriega okay on any
given month within 10 days from the end
of the month we'd have a total tally of
our operation and our accounts payable
including the general Noriega payable
portion at that time I would notify the
general is representative that we were
ready to pay and for them to please
specify how they wanted the payments
made any time say you're paying you know
they say seven million dollars in one
month well he didn't necessarily need
seven million dollars cash it's possible
that he had several needs around the
world and I think he just found that a
little
more convenient for him to say well I
count so-and-so in such a bang for two
million that one an accountant so-and-so
at this bank two million another million
to such an I don't let me interrupt you
there for a minute I don't want to
surmise what he did what I want to find
out is what you specifically did did you
receive a specific instruction through
general Noriega yes sir we receive
specific instructions and we carried
them out okay and the carrying out
involved what placing money in a
specific account somewhere or in Panama
placing money in specific accounts in
specific companies and sometimes cash
payments did you ever make cash payments
I well I had my someone deliver them
yeah my agent deliver them yes sir now
do you wire that money what was there a
particular bank for example a center
point where those dollars were you let's
say X dollars and and you then were got
your where the general wanted his
portion of the money if it was seven
million or ten million distributed how
did you do how did that take place was a
by bank transfer from a particular Bank
of Jews one bank to start to make those
payments
no we I think it's fair to say we used
just about every bank in Panama we would
both know were they wired well if you
wanted money placed outside of Panama
they were wired if it was an account in
a bank within Panama not so but for
instance if a bank since we just about
had balances in all the banks if a bank
if he named a bank and an account number
in the bank you know
of course the bank account number is
meaningless it's a one-time cutout for
their purposes but most of the time I
would have funds available in that Bank
so we just transfer from the account in
that Bank to that new account number you
know what I it would be infrequent that
a bank would be named that we did not
have ongoing ties with and have funds
available in what banks did you use in
Panama for those time what would the
principal banks you did business with
well we use just about every bank in
Panama now as far as I personally use
how many banks are there in Panama
there were about 140 banks about 149 but
you have to remember that when you're
handling the volume of money we were
handling for the number of people we
were dealing with you find that you have
an acquaintance with a client of just
about every bank and we were constantly
we just didn't take these millions of
dollars and park him in the bank we were
paying out bills we were paying out for
equipment and merchandise etc now where
we where all the documents and records
which were attendant to this accounting
process well there were two sets one in
my computer in Miami which was destroyed
and another one in the cartels
accounting office in Panama when was
your computer destroyed it was destroyed
when I was arrested because it was a
hard disk drive computer you cannot move
a machine like that without securing the
disk the agents that
made the seizure apparently we're
unaware that they had to treat the
hard-disk
so you're saying it was destroyed
accidentally by law enforcement
authorities yes sir who were trying to
secure it yes sir they were they moved
it out of my office and they were they
thought they treated it like another
piece of furniture and the information
was lost and they tried their darkness
to put it together but now coming back
to the law enforcement piece of this you
said that you talked to members of the
task force southern Drug Task Force when
you were detained what did you tell them
well I told them that we're making a
mistake that they should talk with me at
lanes before they arrested me were you
prepared to give them information then
did you want to strike a bargain
I wanted to strike a bargain I didn't
think I was going to give them any
information they didn't already have I
think that I wanted all government
agencies to speak to each other before
decision was made on me and did they
listen to you did they offer to take
that under advisement or not no I think
that they thought I was speaking
untruthfully to them and quite frankly
five million dollars seizure was a big
thing seizure for them yeah it was a big
seizure for them it was a you know
the record should show that we have
staff has interviewed the authorities
who made the arrest and that will later
be made part of the record but there was
an indication at the time that they
thought they had a very significant drug
trafficker and they had a big bust and
they thought he was double talking to
them and proceeded I guess with the
arrest isn't it
yes sir all right yes senator how's it
work if I could just go back a step
there were two things that I'd like you
to touch on one of mr. Rodriguez as it
related to the total amounts of dollars
that you paid or instructed to pay over
to general Noriega through from that
starting in 79 until you were arrested
in 83 if you do estimate for us and you
said it got to about 10 million dollars
a month how much over that period of
time did you pay we go from 79 to 83 yes
again we're talking ballpark figures
between 320 million to about 350 million
okay and and this again that Senator
Kerry has elicited - you came by way of
instructions into which it counts -
dislikes the money yes and to which
companies this replaced the money as
well and certain cash payments and
attorneys that trust accounts and and so
forth
wasn't there a particular bank that the
general favored the ABN bank that was
used to then pay out money secured salim
paris were you aware of that yes sir
ATM Bank was a favorite what do you know
about that bank of anything that you can
testify as a relates to general Noriega
sir that Bank is one of the largest
banks in the world has offices in places
you wouldn't believe it's a very
upstanding bank but it was from that
Bank to general or do you have knowledge
that general Noriega used that bank to
then send the monies to Curacao Allen
Paris yes sir many of our a lot of the
generals money for some reason went to
France when you say a lot could you make
an estimate as to how much did you ever
send as much as a million or two million
or three million dollars to parishes yes
sir and I would say to you that there
was any month the money did not go
through France
mr. chairman it was one other thing the
money if mr. Rodriguez could commented
at one point in time when we were
talking about the cartel and the
intelligence information that they
received from general Noriega you said
that in 1982 that the Medellin Cartel
knew all of the agents now are those all
of the agents in Colombia or was it in
Panama and you used the word toyed with
them could you well it's some kind of an
you know what do you mean yeah I was
specifically talking about the agents in
Medellin what they did was I mean there
were some agents who attempted to
infiltrate the organization they were
you know attaché at the Embassy and all
these people that were obviously some
with some sort of drug interdiction
effort that were supposedly working
secretly whether it were they working in
Panama and in Colombia
I don't really know their their personal
schedules but what the cartel did was
the in 1982 1182 yeah they invented they
had some invitations printed that
appeared to come out of a government
agency of a Colombian government agency
for a Christmas party at the
Intercontinental Hotel these invitations
were sent to all of these agents I'm
talking about and Muslims showed up to
the party and once they were there they
were notified that they were there at
the invitation of the cartel that's what
you mean by saying they were really they
knew them all yeah and
a bit arrogance in the way they they
handle it I'm a bit arrogant myself so I
can't so I think people want it and I
think it's important illustrative to
indicate just how compromised the agency
and our Drug Enforcement Agency had had
become that's why when you have reports
that Drug Enforcement agents are all
going to get killed I don't really take
it with too much seriousness because I
know that the cartel knows who's who and
could do horrible things that they
wanted to I think that they have learned
how to use violence graphically and in
the most opportune moment I think the
the assassination of the Colombian
Attorney General a week or so ago is
very indicative that they know how to
use terror now sure you know so they're
not going to kill an agent they will
kill people at random they'll make
statements with their violence Thank You
mr. chairman mr. Rodriguez we want to
try to move fairly rapidly through a
couple of areas and then conclude I just
want to ask you quickly you see this
chart over to your right yes set forth
with the title the organization of the
criminal empire yes sir
can you read those names from where you
are there yes I can do you recognize the
names that you see I laid out on that
chart yes I knew I
what do you recognize them to be I
recognize some competitors of mine some
employees of the general and employees
of general Noriega yes sir and of course
you have a list of who are the
competitors
well it's specifically pretend assess
our Rodriguez says our Rodriguez yes sir
and do you recognize those names as
being members of general Noriega x'
criminal effort yes sir I um I think in
the case of mr. Patel and mr. Assessor
Rodriguez
according to general narrow a general
Noriega and miss interests you did it
according to your best interests I had
the cartels the cartel and I think I
added a measure of responsibility to the
way it was handled
now when you suggest was there a
recklessness about the way they did it
well I think that if you would if you
just checked the record general Noriega
was unable to solidify his power base in
1983 I since I handled the dollars that
were so important I always made sure
that he was just powerful enough to
serve us but never let him get powerful
enough to control us now you believe
that your arrest in 1983 came about as
the result of a betrayal is that
accurate
I believe general Noriega very adroitly
used the American law enforcement
agencies to surgically extract me from
the operation while leaving the
operation intact for him and his cronies
to continue working describe how it came
about your arrest what happened well a
telex was sent out of Panama to the
South Florida Vice Presidential Task
Force identify
as a major money launderer
I think it's important to note that
prior to that telex they didn't know who
I was and the vice president's Task
Force immediately and you know for a
government agency within two or three
months arrested me without doing a very
much investigative work or any other
things I would expect from that type of
agency by doing that you know taking me
out of the picture without hurting the
system that was working I think they
were used by general Noriega do you know
how they specifically learned of your
being at the airport with 5.4 million
dollars in cash there was no question I
could be stopped at any time in the
airport I flew a minimum twice a week I
filed cm IRS I filed my flight plan 48
hours ahead of time as I had to have a
Cuba overfly I mean what I was doing was
not exactly a secret up until then you
know so all this time you had basically
done it with impunity and suddenly the
noose tightened yes sir I did Noriega
was he aware of your opposition to the
m-19 cartel agreement oh absolutely
now why is that a significant part of
why you're here today yes that that more
than any desire for revenge because as
his history now he's been indicted
without my assistance so you know if I
don't really need to do any more to hurt
him he's already been
very hurt but remember that you have a
system that handles multi-billion
dollars shipments yearly that is now in
irresponsible hands and being
infiltrated by communist Condrey it's
only a matter of time before the
Communist cadre take over the cartel and
I'm here are you saying but you say that
after that having described a brutal war
in which the cartel wiped out the
Communist cadre or much of it yeah
absolutely I think more than anything
that got their attention I think that
that opened up the eyes of these people
to the kind of power and the kind of
effort that can be put together by an
organization of this type so you just
what you're saying is so what you I
think described is that you see the
ability of people now to understand the
power that's there and you see a
resurgence of this is that what you're
saying a continued let's put it like
this Fidel Castro's best effort with
m-19 was pitiful compared to and to the
cartels best effort it was proven on the
battlefield I think when you have a
victory like that especially someone
like Castro or the Sandinistas they're
bound to reevaluate their position and
it would be logical to take over the
cartel and I think that initial more
drug trafficking or drug trafficking
yeah
the cartel because it's an ongoing
concern there's a tremendous amount of
goodwill in that organization just like
in any other have you seen did you
witness growth in two other countries of
the narcotics trafficking in a similar
way that began to subvert institutions
and
and change the politics there's a very
good word being used lately it's called
the narco kleptocracy and that is not a
figment of somebody's imagination every
Central and South American country now
without exception has a group of people
that are dependent on the cartel the
cartel does not just control drugs
it controls industries not factories
industries there is not a central or
South American country that the cartel
cannot influence economically and
politically and until you realize that
you cannot deal with though was their
relationship you became aware of between
the Colombian drug cartel or drug
traffickers and the Mexican well the
Mexicans get there a lot of their
product cocaine from the cartel they
also have a an asset which is a 2000
mile border with the United States which
they sell access to that to that access
so the Mexicans and the Colombians are
natural and and they worked that's why
it's an essential part of the drug route
to the United States is obviously their
order is that accurate
was there a dispute between the Mexican
drug traffickers and the Colombians yes
what was that disappeared about money
and money and control yes to a certain
extent you know there is no single
simple dispute these things grow because
they're having
going concern and you have jealousies
you have how how is that dispute
resolved well the the Mexicans were put
on a cash basis by the cartel what does
that mean
that means when they flew down to pick
up their merchandise they had to fly
down money to pay for you know and you
know why did the Colombians operate in
Mexico now know the they are the
Mexicans operate in Mexico and the
Colombians cooperate with them where
they're allowed to but the border
belongs to the Mexicans now we're going
to follow up mr. Rodriguez we're gonna
follow up at a subsequent time probably
an executive session on further
identification of banks and individuals
but I'd like you just to describe for me
a little more particularity than New
York banking process how that you know
who would you meet with in the bank for
instance can you okay every bank that I
dealt with has a representative was that
a I mean everybody who has a portfolio
has a presentative you know that's
nothing unusual about that is there
except that our representatives aren't
found on the listing in the bank
directory so you had a special we think
it well a special man to deal first I
had a special man to deal with manager
contact them do you have a name that
somebody you could telephone
I contacted their Panamanian branch I
would say look I'm gonna I gotta be in
New York on such a day I got this CD and
in this loan and this net I want to
discuss and I'll be there at 9 o'clock I
mean would you walk into the bank or
somewhere else
they would have the limousine meet me
and bring me and limousine meet you at
the airport
yes sir and bring you in yes sir and
would any representative meet you at the
airport I would normally have somebody
waiting for me when I got there and I
would be your person know their person I
was there and they would escort it would
assign me you know I would take care of
did you know who you were looking for
when you first arrived at the bank well
after a while I knew the fellows that
were in charge of it you know I do know
them by name to this day no sir and down
no because that's there was a very real
reason why we went through this type of
charade we were breaking laws in a very
big manner and you always have to have
plausible deniability and the New York
banks are no fools you know so everyone
well that may be questionable well I
found him to be they engaged in the
business and they undertook it and some
banks have already paid fines I think
grossly insufficient well their minds
for laundering but thank you but that
gives you a tremendous insight into how
sophisticated they are I'm doing 43 J
years in jail they pay fines when they
get caught that's exactly the point I'm
trying to make you know so I guess I'm
not as smart as they are I mean I think
the banks I don't know senator I'm not
on the Banking Committee but if there's
any one ingredient in this process that
would assist us it is to make it harder
to move large amounts of cash isn't that
accurate yes logistics is the biggest
problem in money laundering and banks
have resisted those processes that would
somehow create greater accountability
for the movement of cash precisely and
there's there's a there's a wait we've
passed yeah you know we have the $10,000
I'm a very strict money-laundering bill
that for the first time brings in some
accounting and holds the banks
themselves accountable
and let me tell you that that we face
tremendous tremendous opposition and we
only explored the very superficially
some of the violations I would like to
get into this later on with mr.
Rodriguez at future sessions I think
that the real issue is is the
international regulation the
international regulation yeah precisely
as long as they haven't helped with the
internet with foreign branches and the
foreign branches correct priests and the
out as the foreign branches the form
ranch but there was incredible
resistance to legislation which would
hold them accountable up until this time
they they could operate with impunity
because I guess they would get a a slap
on the wrist and a fine of $10,000 per
transaction even if they were caught it
was basically well you're suggesting is
gonna affect their bottom line terribly
total total forfeiture of all money
you're dealing with that's now now the
law but I think we we would probably mr.
Rodriguez benefit by having the
opportunity to look at some of the other
areas that are still wide open and
probably being utilized by some of the
banks which at your service you go to
the man who beat the system you see to
find out how to shore up the system it's
one of the things I suggested with
Senator Kerry I may be criticized for
saying this but it seems to me that
you've been in prison a number of years
now already that it's rather incredible
that there has not been an effort made
by our law enforcement people
recognizing your knowledge of the system
etc to attempt to utilize you not in
terms of exposing people because the
safe houses have been have been changed
the corporations have been changed many
of the people have been changed but as
it relates to dealing with this whole
system and at least to get your
knowledge and your expertise and attempt
to utilize them and notwithstanding that
you may have been interviewed on several
occasions it's just that kind of lack of
Kim
it just gets this senator and I think
some others like Senator Kerry's and a
deacon Seany
so riled up when we hear about this war
on drugs it is absolutely it if it
weren't so serious it would be laughable
but but it but I don't have words
sufficient it expressed you the contempt
I have for those who should know better
who really who really carry this on and
and and and try to the guile beguile the
Congress and the people it said for
about a meaningful effort in the
meaningful war here you had a person who
ran the money operation for the cartel
for years who hasn't had and hasn't been
utilized in terms of the information
were not for senator Kerry and his
committee etc that has has brought this
to the fore you'd still be languishing
there we would be without your
information I don't I don't mean to put
a medal on senator though my gosh we
should be able to draw on your side I
like to be fair at all times because I
find that life works out for me better
that way
in all fairness with the things that
we're discussing today after having some
corroboration and so forth
in 1983 sounded pretty foolish to these
people because they put them in a
position that they had to admit that
they were totally out of control and
totally foolish that they were backed is
the fact is you told them in 1983 people
didn't want to listen isn't that
accurate precisely because they made
their own judgments well like I said
they would have to it's a pretty
mind-boggling thing to to hear and it's
and it's even more mind-boggling that it
was getting by them and it's still
getting by them well it's it's for
coming out now and and I think there's a
lot more of it to come out but let me
let me come to a couple of point we we
need to try to move towards the end here
and I want to turn to mano to be able to
make some comments if he wants to at the
end also let me just ask you quickly
have members of brigade
2506 been involved in drug trafficking
yes sir
you know that personally yes I do sir
how important are the strike that
question has Cuba infiltrated the drug
community to a certain degree absolutely
and you personally I understand that
Cuban intelligence knows about the drug
trafficking business specifically sir I
was Cuban intelligence intelligence made
an attempt to recruit me when was that
8081 III I do mind you ever report that
to anybody no okay
there's the describe for us if you will
again fairly directly and succinctly the
threat that you believe this poses to to
to your country to our country well you
know and I want to say it's my country i
I feel American know even though America
is a hard place to love because she
often treats you badly but when we say
that are you speaking about the Cuban
experience yes are you talking about the
size of Israel that Cubans have about
Castro I'm talking about the Bay of Pigs
the lack of air cover do some of the
other things that have brought you've
never had an argument with this country
and other respects that you know sir a
july's you know I've studied Marxism
socialism capitalism fascism
I made a I chose capitalism out of
ratiocination not out of an accident if
the cartel and the cartels assets get
taken over by communist elements
here's what you're going to have you're
going to have a self-funded
Revolutionary attempt inside the u.s.
drugs go to the lowest exons of this
society to the highest the lowest h
loans
make great recruits if you control their
drug flow you have potential recruits
they'll listen to Marxism or any kind of
activity for anything any kind of
activity so you're going to have a
potential communist cell in every ghetto
in every city in the u.s. can I ask you
something further on that is it not
accurate that other terrorist or
ideologically fanatical groups are
drawing on the profits of the narcotics
trade to fund whatever their operation I
can tell you unequivocally that the
heroin trade on Columbia is funding
Palestinians
I mean it's mind-boggling are you
familiar with the trade in the Bekaa
Valley no sort of no okay coming back to
that question I asked you said
fundamentally absolutely does that mean
terrorist groups or ideological a
fanatical groups of right or left isn't
that accurate yes sir both right on that
but I'm concerned with the leftists
because they're the most organized
they're the most ideologically fanatics
you can find once they get the ghettos
organized you have the highest echelons
of society that are subject to blackmail
you may not be able to take the son of a
government bureaucrat and pay him to
give you information on his father's
activities but you can blackmail him
you can controi drug flow now with the
potential he is enormous enormous let me
ask you now with respect to that sort of
ideological you you've been a supporter
living in the Cuban community
passionately anti-communist and
anti-castro you've also been supporter
though not necessarily passionate about
it but a supporter of the Contras is
that accurate yes sir are you aware of
whether or not narcotics
proceeds at some time may or may not
have supported contra efforts yes sir
narcotics proceeds were used to sure of
the Contra effort did you personally
play a role in some of the transfer of
that money yes I did and are you
familiar with the name of a company
called frigid icicles they put that on
us
yes sir I am what is that company well
it's a shrimp processing warehouse but
more importantly it was one of the
Front's that we used
did you set it up what role did you play
in it I was a key person in setting up
the interlocking chain of companies her
own three buddy finger hit boom titania
and are you familiar with the company
called ocean hunter yes sir what was
ocean hunter ocean hunter was the agent
an agent for free what if he goes it was
supposed to import shrimp into the US
was that part of the interlocking
network that you talked about yes sir
did you launder money I have laundered
money for that Network yes sir and did
some of that laundered where payments or
arrangements made by which the Contras
could receive money through fridge or a
FICO's yes sir you arranged that I threw
my intermediaries I made it possible
right and
did that particular company receive
250,000 dollars in humanitarian
assistant funds from the State
Department yes sir he didn't was any of
the money traceable to drugs or to
drug-related transactions the money that
we you're talking about the money that
we provided that's right no sir
and why was that because we were experts
at what we do
and you created enough cut outs to do
that is that accurate yes you want to
explain how the money moved well I had a
con a VA zone with US intelligence or
let's knock on US intelligence let's
call whoever was running the resupply
we're gonna leave the names out for now
we're gonna come back to this in a few
weeks but I want to know anyway talk
about how the money-laundering moved I
had a as I said I I had the contact man
who supplied me with the needs for cash
the locations and the agents that they
were going to use to receive the money
and when contact was made with me I
would deliver on it any country any
place a chairman if I might just ask at
this point million the the people who
receive this money were they aware of
the fact that this was drug money the
proceeds came from drug money
I let's put it like this centered the
amount of the contra percent in the
field did not but the men who made the
contact with me did at that time I was
under indictment I mean I was red-hot
and it was surprising to me to be
contacted when I was in such a
potentially uh who did you make contact
with and we that we really want to hold
on yes an area piece and we promised in
this process we would do we do have some
documentation we have documents from the
companies etc if I could just ask you
would you do you recognize the document
that's in front of you well this is a
because I handled so much money yes I do
recognize that you want me to explain
when do you recognize what do you
recognize that document to be this is a
not a double entry system was this the
heart of your accounting documents this
is a part of my personal notation as to
what I did with the monies that I
received whom I receive them for and
what I did with them and this was part
of your official records which law
enforcement authorities seized yes that
accurate yes it is and this document
which was seized which you recognize was
placed into evidence by the federal
government in the trial against you for
which you're now serving time is that
accurate yes sir
now I direct your attention to the top
notation on the headings of this
document what is the first heading in
that top column the first heading is an
abbreviation for Miami Miami and the
numbers and figures that are listed
underneath it reflect what they reflect
monies that I took out of search out of
the
consolidating process for my personal
use the next heading says what the next
heading says CIA
what is that CIA refer to it refers to a
one shipment of money I received it was
the CIA the CIA we know is that the in
Central Intelligence Agency yes sir
and what what what is your accounting
show with respect to the CIA it shows
that I received a shipment of three
million and change sometime in the
middle of the month probably do you know
what that was for
well I always got instructions with it
and I I carried out the instruction did
that have something to do with supply
efforts to the Contras you don't know I
don't remember this dough no not at that
point that question is is inappropriate
at that point that's my mistake
but that did reflect a distribution of
funds by U with respect to CIA is that
accurate yes sir okay this will be made
part of the record as exhibit number
fourteen fourteen thank you
also I might remark this was government
exhibit number twelve in your criminal
trial put into evidence by the federal
prosecutor yeah we were surprised when
they put that in were you ever asked
about that no sir were you ever asked
what the notation CIA meant no nobody
has ever asked you know sir we try to
have this document not put into evidence
and the government was adamant about
putting it in so they put it in all
right we are now at the hour of noon and
there is a great deal more to go in let
me just confirm you know I'm satisfied
on that i minister
senator d'amato before we close this
session of the hearings do you have any
comments that you'd like to make at this
time mr. chairman
once again we have a witness
well uniquely can give us a in-depth
look at the magnitude of the operation
of the drug cartel the manner in which
it has been able to corrupt public
officials in literally all of the
countries although he's testified with
particularity as it relates to Panama
he's given us a glimpse of how we can
even defeat when it turns its forces on
to the m-19 that we have been in the
Colombian government has been engaging
for a number of years or you want to
send the power of it the most shocking
how it has been able and how we have our
own intelligence community our own
defense establishment and its
intelligence operations betrayed our own
agents by coming together with these
dictators and opportunists and being so
superficial in our judgments that we
would entrust the lives of our American
citizens our Drug Enforcement Agency and
put them at risk by dealing with the
scum like Noriega it's outrageous what
I've said commentary
Lord knows how many others and how many
other countries have been placed at
peril Milian says they toyed with them
how many have succumbed what about wiki
commentary in Mexico what about our
agents in
who have been sacrificed along the way
and it's a sad commentary and there's
something mr. chairman that I would hope
that in the fullness of time your
efforts in those of this committee and
others will begin to sensitize those in
in charge those in this administration
and future administration's to the kind
of commitment that we're entitled to and
that we can't continue to do business as
usual with these petty tyrants and
sometimes we take these superficial
attitudes well who else do we have there
and that the threat of this insidious
drug epidemic and the power that it
wields is real and that the danger has
penetrated the United States in our
homes and our communities and yes it has
even corrupted and co-opted out our own
institutions at the highest level where
we have lost the capacity and judgment
to make the proper kinds of distinctions
and who we deal with and how we deal
with them so mr. chairman I say that I
think this is just the beginning of what
has to be a commitment from at least the
congressional institution and hope that
we can get our colleagues to join us in
and not in a political sense Democratic
Republican liberal conservative we've
heard testimony from witness after
witness how all of the ideological
forces have been financed whether it be
the Contras whether it be the m-19
whether it be the El Salvadorian
guerrillas now they have drawn upon
these dollars for their financing of
their ideological revolutions mr.
Chairman I I commend you for your
tireless efforts in this area
I look forward to working with you and
why I'm not going to put a gold star in
million because I'd probably like to say
it do you ever regret when you look at
this what you did and how you used that
a senator rain of yours that God gave
you a good brain obviously then let me
say this senator there is some
mitigation to my life it hasn't come on
here I didn't come here to I came here
to bury Caesar not to praise and but I
think later on you'll find out that I'm
not entirely as bad as I saying that are
you do I mean are you sorry for the path
you chose do you feel I mean the years
you're serving now do you feel a sense
of waste do you feel like you lost
something that could have been different
are you basically hey this is the way it
is well a center a belong to a group of
people who are willing to do moral
reprehensible acts for ends that are
what we feel in the best interest of our
ideology we use these justifiable means
to break the law and when we're caught
we pay the way it is well I appreciate
the insight that you've given us and the
fact that you have been willing to
cooperate I just want to give you one
chance before we walk out of here is
there any piece of testimony as you've
thought about it is there anything here
because you're serving a long sentence
now but I assure you if you you know lie
to this committee it'll be longer and I
think you understand that yes and you
said that to me this morning before you
even came out here that you understood
that it is everything you've told us
today the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth absolute
then well I have I guess I have a number
of different comments one I noticed that
yesterday issues are already arising
about who's credible who is incredible
and has there been an inconsistency here
or there I would warrant that in this
record will be available for reading
very quickly that when you read it and
go through it the consistency of what
we've heard is extraordinary from person
after person who is declared against
their own interest at great risk
personally to their lives at risk of
further prosecution at risk of us
discovering through other sources
documentation that somehow they didn't
tell the truth and therefore serves even
longer in prison I think when you
measure all those things against what's
been said there's reason to find
enormous credibility in it
it's interesting to note that while Vice
President Bush denied that he made the
call and I accept his word I do accept
his word it also was learned last night
on macneil-lehrer that former NSC
staffer admitted that indeed there was
prior notice given to Castro and said
that was through a different channel
they didn't lead need Noriega now who
knows it was it a staff call was it
someone else was there someone saying
this is representing the vice president
we've been detailed to notify or
something and Brandon gets called in the
night and says the vice president's
office called with the vice president
but the fact is he says he called Fidel
Castro in the dead of night and the fact
is the Castro was noticed and it seems
to me that as you go through the details
of this and analyze this measured
against the past there's further reason
to believe what we've heard I recognized
you know if you go back to the
iran-contra hearings there were
witnesses who came forward with totally
different stories
inconsistent with each other day after
day that has not appeared here witness
after witness has corroborated the
money-laundering corroborated the
network corroborated the names carotid
specificity mr. chair with specificity
with great specificity and I am one who
and I think most people share this with
me I certainly don't quickly forget the
fact that there were long and indignant
and repeated denials by the White House
and others about selling arms to the
Koran there were long and repeated
denials by the CIA in the State
Department about those and many other
things including illegal support of the
Contras during the period of the Boland
amendment there were repeated denials
and yet factual aberrations bill Webster
in whom I have enormous confidence I
think he's one of the finest public
servants we have in government today and
I think he is moving effectively and
diligently to try to make up for some of
the things that did happen a number of
years ago but the fact is that he's
fired
he has fired some of the people who were
involved in reaching beyond their
permitted scope of duty during this
period that we are talking about right
here and it seems to me that in light of
that as well as past assassination
manuals printed by the CIA as well as
the manag web mining x' and so forth
that we have caused to wait before we
make judgments to wait at least we're
going to see in the months to come a lot
more investigative effort and that will
certainly go on I'd like to just say
quickly at this time that we've seen a
significant corroboration of a number of
different things in these last days the
witnesses have certainly detailed
general Noriega x' involvement with a
Colombian cartel to smuggle narcotics to
launder money provide them protection
some have even testified to his
involvement in murder
Noriega sale of weapons to the
Salvadoran rebels has been confirmed by
at least three witnesses his
relationship with US officials has been
confirmed his connections between drug
traffickers and the connections between
drug traffickers incidentally and
Contras supply efforts of one kind or
another whether private or otherwise
have been mentioned in the instance of
Gonzalez in the instance of Mike Palmer
mentioned by mr. Rodriguez by mr. rich
by mr. Blandon and mr. Colton we have
seen narcotics diverted to ranches and
air strips all across various parts of
Central America and we have learned of
connections to Cuba of connections to
m-19 we have learned obviously of an
enormous network of narcotics
trafficking that has come to threaten US
foreign policy interests and that has
come to threaten institutions of this
country itself there are clearly many
questions left to be asked there are
clearly whole areas of inquiry that have
been opened about by this that or even
beyond the scope of this committee
certainly beyond its current staffing
ability and not just foreign policy
issues but law enforcement issues
international banking issues national
security issues and obviously
intelligence community issues I share
with Senator D'Amato and I thank him for
his having joined me here for these
three and a half days he has long been
interested in and concerned about this
issue
he has come at it from different
committee position he does not serve on
the Foreign Relations Committee nor on
my subcommittee but as an interested
member and as the minority member of
ranking member of the Narcotics Task
Force he has been
important I think to helping to draw
this out and to underscore its
importance to all of us I also want to
thank Senator Pell because senator Pell
is chairman of this committee is
currently at an INF trip in Europe but
he has been a very patient and very
supportive of the subcommittee and of
its efforts and of our staff and without
his support that we wouldn't have been
able to continue up until this point and
so at this point we will adjourn until
March when we will have a subsequent
inquiry and follow-up when some of the
things raised here today as well as new
material let me before we do close I
have here a report on panama prepared by
a six-member bipartisan Senate staff
delegation as the result of a trip in
mid-november of 1987 the trip was
authorized by the Senate leadership to
gather information on the situation in
Panama and report it back to the Senate
with recommendations on what progress if
any had been made in restoring democracy
the delegation was comprised of foreign
policy aides to Senator Kennedy Duren
Berger D'Amato
Graham of Florida and the professional
staff of the majority and the minority
and we will make that a part of this
record and finally I also want to thank
Senator Helms would have been here this
week but for a personal family emergency
and he has been supported with this
overall effort not just about Panama
where he has obviously had concerns but
across the board and it was Senator
Helms who made the comment in our
initial inquiry look let's do this and
let the chips fall where they may
so I'm appreciative to his staff also
for their support in the effort we stand
adjourned until March
you